so what came after sourcefed then after
sourcefed i went straight to crunchyroll
are you just giving an offer or yeah i
was given an offer and
um i was actually given an offer while i
was at sourcefed and i
was like oh no i didn't hear that like
nothing happened
um but then after i left we had like a
clean break with sourcefed they knew i
was so distraught over the gaming
channel
no no like please we don't want you to
like go postal so just like we
um so i went to crunchyroll and it was
actually
a lot of fun but i ended up
shouldering a lot of the production i
thought it was going to be more like
sourcefed where
there's a crew and i would have some
production say but they hired me as
talent
slash producer so i guess i should have
been expecting more of that
responsibility but
it was it was really ragtag and
um and like you know what you were
saying before about the anime community
crunchyroll has a very aggressive anime
community um both
well we know don't worry it's a good
thing and a bad thing because some
people are
fans of the company that just want the
company to do well but then there are
people that are like criticizing it
which
makes sense too the company should do
better right like there's a lot of kind
of factors to it where you can't really
get mad at the whole situation
yeah and it was hard answering all of
that right like it was hard
i feel like you got an impossible job
you know thank
the words that she wants to hear
five words that make you do this i mean
you know you were just like a martyr for
crunchyroll
honestly like well you know every time i
saw crunchyroll videos you know i think
because everyone just has that air of
skepticism towards control unfortunately
you know and you know we've worked with
country role you know and i think we've
also been skeptical of crunchyroll but
yeah i think the viewers especially
love dogging on crunchyroll i mean i
mean controversial they're the boogie
man
yeah concho could have had like [ __ ]
jesus christ you know reeves
or keanu reeves say the same thing right
and people would find problems with them
you know
i feel i feel crunchyroll fans like not
crunchy fans but crunch all haters quote
unquote
to like kind of get a little too over
obsessive with criticizing crunch roll
to the point where it's like okay
i get it like yes it's not a perfect
company they have a lot of stuff to work
on
but give them a [ __ ] prank oh that
means a lot like jesus christ like
and especially like again it's like you
had that impossible job of like
because all i feel all of the arrows
were like
pointed towards you right because you
were literally the face now they have a
face
yeah now they have a face and person to
point out right and i just felt
really [ __ ] bad that they wrapped
that point blind me
yeah i would like send you messages
being like are you okay because like if
i were you
i would not be able to [ __ ] handle
that yeah i remember actually i very
very specifically and vividly remember
uh one of your messages where you're
like hey are you and he was like so
you you're being so careful with me
you're like are you okay like
i saw the last video like it's not your
fault i was like
oh um you know what i'm not reading the
comments anymore
yeah yeah yeah i'm like i think i'm okay
it was just like a warning call to be
like
don't read the comments yeah yeah yeah
[ __ ] hell
and it was so weird because um i don't
want to mention specifically video but
they weren't even mad at me it wasn't me
that they were mad at they were just mad
at something else that was happening
which was ad related
and they pushed it onto the video and
then they it kind of like turned into
its own monsters it was a sticky
situation yeah and i'm like
that's the weird thing they're not even
mad at me like i can't really
i didn't know how to feel about it right
like if they're not hating on me but
i'm also the face so they're like [ __ ]
you and you're facing these ads i'm like
that's not my bad
like it's the weirdest kind of hate to
get as a content creator i feel yeah
it's like it's not your fault but [ __ ]
you yeah they're like i'm so sick of
seeing your face every five seconds like
while i'm watching
attack on titan i was like i'm not even
sorry
so yeah that was that was interesting
but again because they weren't really
necessarily
angry at me as a person again i had that
like veil of protection where
i'm like like it's it's okay i hate
my company that i work for and represent
with my face
but yeah